des harnais de secours sont constitué la
plus importante se forment à bourges
cette armée de la loire 70 mille hommes
et 150 canon fait face début décembre
1870 en pleine gosse aux prussiens et à
leurs alliés du royaume de bavière
une partie du sort de la guerre se joue
ici au nord d'orléans dont la bouille
dans le froid et c'est un carnage 9000
morts et blessés en quelques dizaines
d'heures on peut préciser quand même que
dans la nuit qui a suivi on pense à tous
les blessés qui étaient sur le champ de
bataille il a fait dit-on 20 degrés en
dessous de zéro
d'autre part les soldats qui se sont
battus ici étaient épuisés par des
marches très longue
j'ai évoqué le fait qu'ils étaient
souvent mal habillé il faut se rappeler
qu'en 1870 les soldats sont si beaucoup
aux morts de la du froid de la maladie
plus encore que des balles de l'ennemi
aujourd'hui les victimes françaises et
prussiennes sont honorés de la même
manière un siècle et demi à passer et ce
temps-là a permis de comprendre tout
l'enjeu européen durant ses 150 ans nous
avons eu 75 ans de conflit avec
l'allemagne et 75 ans de paix et de paix
grâce à l'union européenne donc plus que
jamais nous commémorons aussi l'amitié
franco allemand de chaque fois que nous
le pouvons
et ici nous le pouvons aujourd'hui
allouani la bataille
allouani un musée permet de replonger
dans ce drame de la fin du 19e siècle
pour aider celui à maintenir la mémoire
de ceux de 1870 une web série est
désormais en ligne sur le site du
ministère des armées
[Musique]